I know with the play today
every day I gotta find a new game it's
so hard how could I possibly find a game
that is greater than any game I have
ever played before
it won't happen what is this
oh oh oh are you serious
the gravity so gravity goes up they came
from her boobs
finally thank you YouTube god we did it
we found the best game ever oh my god oh
my god
I'm crying don't tell Martha whatever
you do do not tell Marcia the [ __ ] is
this not always skip give me to the
tennis
oh my god they always drag out the thing
oh my god look at the gray oh my god oh
it's it's one of those videos guys oh my
god they whatever alright alright I'm 26
oh my god I can't give me a shout out of
that Jesus why am i kicking the [ __ ] out
of these women could this be the
greatest game the music the gameplay the
poopy bear sin
listen you're watching the video stop
judging me alright what's going on here
oh oh oh what's happening
Oh what just happened
oh thank you Jesus
can you stop I mean keep going
Wow Wow biscuit shits transforming
amazing Oh whoever plays this for the
gameplay is clearly lying
I can't lose now I'm Nick my controllers
not working my god damn your xbox god
damn your ex-boss I will never forget
this hey maybe it's not so bad after all
you're going down oh I think there's a
story going on but I haven't really
understand any of it
it's a good game it's got a good
soundtrack it gets cut good gameplay
it's got good music
it's got good good story huh I am
playing it for all those reasons man
this era in the game is so good look how
clever they are they clearly spent all
the money on the boobs listen what you
need to do is go close to a wall then
you got to turn around and then go god
damn it I try to look at my kitties here
oh my god I can see my own panties this
is better than younger simulator oh my
god in panties oh my god oh no she's
transforming to see what did we show
transforming to oh my god
they pop out as everyone knows the less
armor you wear the more armor you have
what the [ __ ] is this what the [ __ ] was
that
oh my [ __ ] god how can this game be
so good I don't even know how I
activated that [ __ ] god I need to know
how how did I do that
what a [ __ ] welcome Jesus Christ
rainbow panties yes please I will take
this and this and this
oh my god rainbow panties ah Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas indeed secret
ninja attack what are you gonna do what
is she doing
she became huge oh my god she's
attacking with her ass oh my god she has
no tits oh my god this is child porn
what the [ __ ] am i doing what the [ __ ]
is happening oh no I don't want to see
her transform it's weird this is weird
she's like eight what the [ __ ] no thanks
okay that's adorable why am I still
playing this game the video is done long
ago Jesus Christ and she said this
attack is my favorite attack the ass
attack is the best attack this town has
ever knew
good I can't
my controller this away my controller
doesn't work god damn you xbox no no
it doesn't work how could this happen
No god damn it I can't
why
why step by Jack
how much money do you have
you